De Sitter's observations were of what's known as a binary star system.
Now a binary star system has as you might guess two stars,
and these two stars orbit around each other.
More precisely, they're orbiting on the center of mass.
These orbits often are very small, very small radius and also very fast
and so what De Sitter did was look at the light and made it from these stars
a different points in their orbit.
So for now, let's just pay attention to star one and just ignore star two.
So we know that if it's going around this way, well at this instant in its trajectory,
its velocity would be pointing in that direction.
Eventually, these stars are going to make it all the way around here
and its velocity will be pointing in exactly the opposite direction.
Now if the speed of light were not constant in all reference frames,
if you really could throw a light forward like a baseball and when we look at this light on earth,
we might expect to see some strange effects.
I'm actually going to let an animation speak for me on this one.
So here we have our one star of our binary system and it's making a circular orbit.
Now at this upper point in the orbit, you can see it's moving away from this detector over here.
At the lower point of its orbit down here, it's moving towards the detector
giving more additional velocity to the light, and if you look over here you can see that that light,
which was admitted at the lower portion, actually overtakes the other light that was admitted earlier.
This would lead to some really strange observations.
So for example, at some point when this and this light arrive at the exact same time
like from the bottom and top, well that means we'll be seeing the same star in two places,
and it turns out De Sitter found that that doesn't happen.
This was a very clever experiment
to confirm experimentally the second postulate of special relativity.